quelle joie pour nous conseillers
départementaux de vous réunir dansre AR
Futuroscope avec c'est une première avec
un grand merci à
stitêtre
mais
merci cas
trava équipes et merci pour votre
accueil j'ai une pensée pour tous les
collègues d'hier et d'aujourd'hui et
pour tous ceux qui ont cru dans ce
projet dès le premier jour au côté de
Bruno Belin nous avons eu raison laarena
furoscope c'est une grande fierté il
s'est passé quelque chose à tel point
qu'on sait plus comment on vivait sans
aide merci Guillaume de Russé
qui suit tout cela de très
près cette réussite collective se
vérifie moi après moin événement après
événement match après match concert
après
concert je crois que nous pouvons
applaudir les équipes de l'ARA
[Musique]
futurosc l' année j'ai souhaité un
nouveau format pour réunir ensemble
toutes celles et tous ceux qui portent
auut eff fort les couleurs de la Vienne
une cérémonie qui associe les agents de
notre collectivité les élus du
territoire ainsi que tous les
partenaires publics privés et
associatifs avec lesquels nous
travaillons au
quotidien un choix fédérateur qui comme
je l'ai toujours fait
l'unité et le
rassemblement si j'ai la conviction
profonde que nos différences sont
complémentaire je sais également que
nous sommes reliés par un destin
commun nous vivons n travaillons sur le
même territoire et chacun à sa façon
nous sommes des ambassadeurs de la
Vienne du nord au sud de l'est à
l'ouest soyons F de notre département
n'oubl jamais n la
M
inusion solidarité VI Excell
j' le F que
[Musique]
vouszécierustration T nous
Lesur pour construire publ service
desintérê génér
merci
àice communication
[Musique]
pour
gr merci aux maires et aux élus de la
Vienne qui s'engagent pour leur communes
et leurs
habitants je mesure la valeur de cet
engagement au service des autres qui
exige de plus en plus de courage
notamment face aux agession répété
qu'ils subissent j'ai une pensée ce soir
pour chacun d'eux et en particulier les
quatre MRES de la Vienne agressés en
2023 je leur témoigne à nouveau notre
soutien total protégeons les faisons
front commun contre ces violences
inacceptables qui menace notre
République fracture notre pays et abîme
notre
démocratie je tiens à remercier
marieaneam pour son son action au sein
de l'Association des maires de la Vienne
et le soutien qu'elle apporte au
quotidien avec ses collègues à tous les
élus de notre
département merci également Monsieur le
Préfet d'avoir pris la mesure de la
gravité de la situation pour renforcer
la sécurité de chacun
deux c'est une réalité que vivent au
quotidien nos sateurs pompiers nos
policiers et nos gendarmes à qui
j'exprime notre gratitude et notre
reconnaissance il nous protège avec
courage et s'engage pour sauver des
vies parfois au péril de
l'aleur une vie d'engagement que partage
aussi t ceux quivrent au service des
autres et du bien commun avec le sens de
l'intérêt général chevillé au
corp j'ai aussi une pensée pour tous nos
enseignants et l'ensemble des personnels
soignants qui sont pas épargné par ces
violen je voudrais également saluer
toutes les associations de la Vienne et
le bénévol qui participe à la cohésion
sociale de notre département
le département c'est avant tout la
solidarité entre les générations avec
une attention
particulière pter au plus fragile
d'entre nous solidarité avec les
familles et les enfants en détresse dont
nous avons la
responsabilité solidarité avec nos aînés
et toutes les personnes en situation
dehicap dans ces domaines comme ce de la
santé et de l'insertion les défis sont
immenses et je crois
à la force des solidarités locales et à
la promesseune société plus
inclusive sur le
handicap beaucoup de choses positives
sont nées des États généraux que nous
avons lancé en 2022 une nouvelle
dynamique et plusieurs actions ont été
engagées par exemple la création de
point d'accueil et d'information de la
maison départemental des personnes
handicapées dans nos maisons des
solidarités la bénisé français ice et ce
n'est que le
début le combat
continue merci à valérieug Rose-Marie
Berto Anne Florence bourin CIB pot et
benoî Coel qui porte nos politiques de
solidarité quand le département la
culture accessible au plus grand nombre
au plus près de nos jeunes et au cœur
des territoires ruraux nous sommes dans
cette même logique de
solidarité je ne connais pas d'autres
département merci àouch qui eu l'audace
de créer un festival comm les heur
vagabondes avec des concerts gratuits
sur tout le
territoire cet été nous fêons ces 20 ans
rendez-vous pour le concert d'ouverture
à
CH une société plus inclusive c'est
aussi une société qui donne la parole
aux jeunes à l'image du conseil ental
des jeunes mis en place depuis 2 ans
notre politique jeunesse à vocation à
éclairer les citoyens de demain et à
l'heure pour transmettre ses valeurs de
respect et
d'inclusion merci Valerie chevassier
d'accompagner no 55 jeunes élu il donne
à chacun de nous une bien belle image de
notre
jeunesse en 2024 le département de la
Vienne a décidé de nous faire vivre les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
je vous donne rendez-vous ici même sur
le parmis de l'Arena de l'Arena
Futuroscope le 25 mai prochain pour
accueillir la flamme olympique faire
rayonner la Vienne ces 266 communes son
patrimoine voilà
l'objectif mais aussi et surtout
associer nos sportifs nos bénévoles nos
clubs comme le font chaque jour Pascal
gu et al joyeux dans la mise place de
notre politique
sportive alors en 2024 un seul mot
d'ordre la Vienne pour tous tous pour la
Vienne notre engagement pour la Vienne
c'est aussi l'équité entre les
territoires
l'équité c'est la mobilité pour tous
essentielle pour le monde
rural ce sont les 4780 km de route
départementale qui jalonne la
Vienne ce sont sont de gros très gros
investissements et nous les assumons
avec beaucoup de détermination sous la
responsabilité de
G
l'équité c'est aussi la FRE que nous
déployons partout jusqu'au confin de la
Vienne avec sébrine SAÉ et françois
b nous allons continuer à nous battre au
côté de l'État pour que les opérateurs
tiennent les délais que la fibre et le
Très Haut Débit arrivent partout et pour
tous en
l'quité c'est encore le devoir que nous
avons de continuer à faire vivre nos
bourgs et nos compagnes cette Vienne
qu'on aime qu'on met au cœur de notre
projet celle de nos territoires de nos
activités agricoles et
industrielles continuons à bâtir
ensemble une ruralité dynamique et
attractive une ruralité
heureuse nous nous y employons au
quotidien avec notre politique
volontariste de soutien aux communes
porté par Pascal
etard je ne connais pas le département
comparable au NES qui s'engage chaque
année à hauteur de 20 million d'euros
pour soutenir les projets structurants
de son territoir des communes et des
communautés de communes d' et réser 20 %
de son budget à
l'investissement je voudrais saluer
Monsieur le Préfet votre action très
positive ainsi que celle de vos écipes
car il faut se féliciter que nous
puissions avancer vite et bien ensemble
très efficacement sur de nombreux
dossiers et projets
communs c'est dans cette même vision
d'aménagement de développement et
d'attractivité de la Vienne que nous
avons créé la SAS foncière 86 la pente
les territoires et les EPCI
elle accompagnera les projets
innovants comme par exemple celui de
l'entreprise cire après sac dans le sud
VI son unité de production de robot le
dshervbage mécanique et automatisé en
agriculture va permettre la création
d'une trentaine
d'emplois c'est juste
remarquable grâce à tous ces
investissements
beaucoup de communes rurales ont
retrouvé les couleurs les commerces et
les services de
proximité derrière tous ces projets
c'est un soutien fort apporté à
l'économie locale c'est de l'emploi pour
nos habitants de l'activité pour nos
entreprises c'est un moteur
d'attractivité pour la Vienne complétant
ainsi l'action du département porté par
Brigit abo en faveur de l'habitat et du
logement
notre travail P la Vienne accueille
toujours de nouveaux habitants même si
vous le savez c'est parfois inégal selon
les territoires d'après les derniers
chiffres publiés parc il y a quelques
jours nous restons le seul département
non côtier de nouvelle Aquitaine dont la
population augmente plus 02 % entre 2015
et 2021
soit plus de 750 habitants en moyenne
par an on l'avait bien noté merci cher
Domini
clé c'est la poursuite de ce renouveau
rural de la Vienne que j'appelle de mux
ce soir si soit les défis la ruralité a
de l'avenir dans notre pays et dans
notre département sans jamais l'opposer
à
l'urb d'autres défis nous attend en
2024 à commencé par le contexte
financier et les contraintes de plus en
plus fortes avec lesquelles il nous faut
assumer nos politiques
publiques plusieurs raisons à
cela un état qui ne compense pas
financièrement complètement les
décisions qu' nous impose et qui deux
sur point ne nous permet pas de lever
l'ôt une crise de l'immobilier qui nous
fait perdre plus de 20 % de recettees de
droit de
mutation quoi qu'il en so nous devons
construire no budgets en conséquence
pour 2024 j'ai demandé à notre exécutif
épaé par notre monsieur
[Musique]
finance de faire des économies on a tous
conscience que la tâche est difficile
mais elle est
nécessaire gouverner c'est
choisir disait pierre m fr aussi
difficil soit les choix dans ceexte
budgétaire tendu nous nous tenons de
tenir un discours de
vérité auprès de nos
concitoyens un discours de vérité c'est
également indispensable face au défi de
l'eau je regrette que cette question
soit si souvent
instrumentalisé alors que nous avons
tous les atouts pour relever ensemble le
défi d'une gestion durable de
l' là aussi c'est le principe d'équité
qui doit é c'est dans une vision
d'équilibre et de dialogue de respect
que le département de la Vienne portera
le futur projet de territoire de gestion
de l'eau sur le bassin du CLIN en y
associant tous les acteurs je sais va
compter sur Joë ptier Jean-Louis Le i
pour contuire cette mission cruciale sur
notre territoire ils pourront évidemment
bénéficier du soutien de Benoît Princet
et de jeanlier JEV parmi nos défis 2024
il y a celui de l'aéroport
outil structurant pour notre territoire
les li commerciales et touristique sont
plébiscités avec un taux de remplissage
proche de 100
% bravo aux équipes de
l'aéroport nous avançons aussi pour
trouver des solution afin de redémarrer
la ligne Poitier lon capital pour nos
acteurs économiques
cette bataille nous la menons pour
l'attractivité de
la c'est d'ailleurs bien ce combat pour
l'attractivité qui motive aussi notre
politique touristique si volontariste
porté
parandrine
etir notre nouvelle marque de
destination touristique officialisé il y
a quelques semaines a bien vocation à
Doer le rayonnement d'avenne et attirer
encore plus de
visiteurs plbit par les professionnel
viendraéter notre offensive en de
tourisme d'affair avec la
[Musique]
créationationésid deett
npement
develementour
je ne sais pas vous mais moi je suis le
plus chauin des habitants de la et ce
qui serait très très
bien je ne sais pas ce que vous en
pensez c'est que nous soyons tous encore
un peu plus
Chud cette attractivité est encore et
toujours portée par notre Futuroscope
don les chiffres rest
remarquables avec près de 2 million de
visiteurs en
2023 les de derniers grandes étapes du
projet vision 2025 imaginez par rodolp
moin et ses équipes en plein
confinement vont désormais voir le jour
l'été prochain avec l'ouverture de
l'Aquascope je suis très impatient de
tester avec vous mes chers collègues nce
pas les
de puis en 2025 la future grande
attraction mission bermud pleine de
promesses également
souhaitons-leur le même succès que
chasseur de tornad élu au printemps
dernier par les professionnels meilleur
attraction au
monde Unis en nos forces en dépassant
lescrivage pour affronter ensemble tous
ces défis c'est dans nos valeurs et je
crois que c'est à cela qu'on reconnaît
la bienenne cultivons cette état
d'esprit et la volonté de demeurer une
terre de projet d'innovation est
excellence l'excellence éducative à
laquelle s'emploi h Collin et Jérôme
neveu passe à la fois par des travaux
d'ampleur dans nos collèges mais aussi
par l'ensemble de projets novateurs
autour du numérique éducatif que nous
avons engagé au service de la réussite
de nos jeunes c'est notre cheval de
bataille a é éteint c'est l'ambition du
pôle numérique pour l'éducation et la
formation qui se dessine au Futuroscope
pour préparer l'École du futur qui
ouvrira ses portes en 2025 à de pas
d'ici c'est unique en
France le pavillon emblématique du
Futuroscope qui accueille l'école de
demain tout un
symbole cette recherche de l'excellence
continuera de nous guider en 2024 dans
tous les domaines afin que la Vienne
demeure un département fier de ses
racines
ouvert sur le monde c'est le chemin que
nous a montré René monori et c'est celui
de la
réussite un département à la pointe de
l'innovation qui attire les talents de
demain un département exemplaire qui
inspire ses voisins un département qui a
foi en
l'avenir je tiens à remercier
chaleureusement toute l'équipe vien qui
m'accompagne depuis maintenant 3 ans
chers collègues merci de votre
confiance
merci également au 1600 collaborateurs
du département pour leur investissement
au service de nos
concitoyens merci à Mar en charge des
relations
Humes à notre Directeur Général des
Services
jeanluc et aux équipes de
directionentour un service public de
qualité au profit des habitants des
usagers et notre vocation
elle ne peut se réaliser qu'avec une
efficace collaboration entre les élus et
nos agents dans le cadre d'un dialogue
social régulier ouvert avec le
représentant du
personnel quotidiennement dans
l'exercice des mission de tous les
agents nous élus et usagés nous savons
que nous pouvons compter sur votre
volonté votre énergie votre
professionnalisme et vos prcieus
compéten pour apporter un service public
de
qualité un grand merci à chacun d'entre
vous pour conclure chers amis je vais me
permettre de paraphraser fier de
couber aller plus vite plus haut plus
fort tous ensemble pour continuer à
construire une vie une vien riche de ses
valeurs exemplaire et
innovante soyez assurés que notre
investissement est et restera total pour
faire de notre
département une Vienne
olympique pour que 2024 soit synonyme de
liberté d'égalité et de fraternité pour
que vive la Vienne belle et heureuse
année à toutes et à
tous